whether he really I mean and this
footage here I mean to warn people at
home this is distressing
this is this is distressing for this
will be distressing for some people to
to look at this says this has clearly
been shot on a mobile phone
just after the attack
he's dressed in a in some sort of of
head covering
and then he's running away I think we
see one person in Pursuit
as well
perhaps one of the individuals that we
see later on there we go
and important to say John to our viewers
who may just be tuning in that the
attacker that you see on your screens
now has been detained by police we
haven't got any footage
um of that
but just so that viewers just joining us
understand that he is now in police
custody yes he he has been he has been
detained we know from the interior
Minister that there was a rapid
intervention I think that the pictures
that we are seeing are are interesting
and informative because it gives us an
idea of how it actually happened